amazon owned mgm it's done
welcome to sidetrek your sci-fi tv and
movie channel
[Music]
so this news is a little bit irritated
for me because basically i have just
concluded editing a video all about how
this deal was definitely going to go
through
basically inspired by a bunch of youtube
videos scam grin one included on
gateworld a little bit about how this
deal might actually get locked up in a
legal battle and i was basically saying
in the video that that's not going to
happen the deal will almost certainly go
through but what would happen in the
different scenarios you can watch that
video because i'm going to stick it on
the end of here i put all the hard work
and at the end of the day i'm not just
going to delete the damn thing
but i've never been happier really to
not need to publish a video because this
deal has gone through
there was a deadline basically for the
ftc to oppose the deal because the ftt
doesn't actually authorize a deal it
basically just has to oppose it or not
if it doesn't oppose it the deal goes
through the deadline for that was
yesterday and it has passed so amazon
and mgm have announced that the deal is
finalized and it is now going to go
through the final stages of the merger
those final stages i'm certain would
have been discussed in detail over the
last 12 months but mgm is going to see a
little bit of a restructure amazing are
going to put their own people in and
things that have been sort of talked
about a great deal over the last 12
months can finally be finalized we can
start getting a few projects green lit
but what projects will they be well if
you're a regular sidetracker you'll know
that amazon have been talking to mgm
about pushing forwards with three big
projects one of those is going to be the
new james bond
the other stargate the project i really
really want to see and the third one
being a big reboot of something mgm
already owned a big franchise hard
reboot of something now they have three
big projects in mind for that
i'm going to tell you what those are in
the next couple of videos
but for today
this is good news because this means
we're actually going to start getting
some official news about stargate and
other projects coming through amazon in
the next few months
they are going to want to have a big
news story something to make amazon
customers and mgm lovers very very happy
those projects will be announced in the
next few months and i cannot wait
fingers crossed for stargate to be one
of them because i know they've been
talking a lot about stargate
but talk is cheap i never want them to
actually sign on the dotted line and get
something in pre-production whether
that's brad wright's project
another project that's been looked at or
a hybrid of the two i don't really care
whether it's a movie or a tv show i
don't really care i just want stargate
announced an official because
let's be honest we've been looking
forward to this since sgu closed and now
we're going to finally get it
so
please watch the video that is now
redundant because you know i put a lot
of work into it so you know give it a
chat and you'll understand actually to
be fair from that video why this was
always going to happen and why mgm
amazon deal could never be opposed by
the ftc
thanks for watching guys if you are new
to the channel please like subscribe hit
the bell notification if you want to
become a fully fledged sidetracker and
support the channel it really really
helps consider hitting that join button
and as always please guys stay safe i'll
see you soon
in about 30 seconds in another complete
new video
the ftc is about to rule on the sale of
mgm to amazon and stargate will quickly
follow but where are we at legally right
now welcome to sidetrack your sci-fi tv
a movie channel
so we're at a critical stage in the ftc
look into the sale of mgm to amazon or
it's merger and there have been a lot of
scare stories out there all over youtube
etc about how
basically the sale might be at risk
that
the ftc don't really like this deal and
that they are maybe going to have a
legal battle to prevent it
but where of all these rumors come from
and
let's be honest what's actually true at
the moment the sale of mgm to amazon is
actually going through
all over the world australia as already
said we have no problem with this the eu
is reportedly about to do the same and
the uk will follow shortly
but really
the only country that matters is the
united states and the ftc because that's
primarily where mgm and amazon operate
so let's have let's dispel a couple of
myths straight away
now people at mgm have spoken to me i
have my inside sources and they've told
me a long time ago and i told you guys
in videos six months ago nearly that
they feel that amazon is kind of being
victimized and the sale was taking a
long time that the ftc were dragging
their feet now they told me at the time
this was because amazon don't pay their
taxes and those are reported to you but
actually it's a bit more complicated
than i've got remember these are
creative types they're not legal types
so they explain things in the way they
understand
but basically they are right in a way
amazon is not the most popular company
in the world
in america and in western europe they're
kind of seen as this big multinational
that don't really have the best business
practice
they're very aggressive they're
destroying the high street and they
don't pay their fair share in tax now
they don't pay their fair share tax
perfectly legally there is a difference
between tax avoidance and tax evasion
basically one is legally using the tax
code and the tax laws to pay as little
taxes possible and the other one is
lying about your income so that you pay
less tax
amazon do the first they pay as little
taxes humanly possible but they do it
perfectly legally and they're very good
at it
this makes them quite unpopular with
some governments which i find
incredibly ironic because it's the
government that create the tax laws that
amazon used to pay as little taxes
possibly in the first place mgm and
amazon actually do have an enemy at the
ftc and actually have tried to get this
person removed from the ftc chair or get
her to recuse herself from
the talking about this deal because
she's been so publicly against amazon
the ftc chair is a lady called khan
who
as we know as sci-fi fans nobody called
khan is ever a bad person right
but she is very vocal against amazon she
does not like their business practices
and she does not think this deal should
go ahead
the ftc basically has five people on the
chair and they vote on whether a deal
can go through or not but at the moment
the fifth chair is actually empty so
it's actually four people and the
current understanding is that it's two
on two the khan on one of the other
chairs
does not want this deal to go through
and the other two see no legal reason
why you shouldn't
they in theory could begin a legal
battle to prevent the sale they could go
to court and argue that this shouldn't
happen in which case the amazon sale
would collapse
but is it likely basically we've got a
couple of little problems with them
going to court
they'd lose
mainly because even if morally amazon
aren't particularly liked and they don't
really like this deal legally amazon
have done nothing wrong we have the
anti-trust laws in america and they
basically say that this deal with amazon
and mgm has to be bad for the public and
somehow it has to cost us more or create
a monopoly in some way
that's not going to happen even though
several trade unions include including
the screenwriters guild are actually
saying that's exactly what will happen
and they are creating a monopoly within
the streaming service in particular the
other side of that coin though is to
consider the fox and disney deal that
went through for 10 times more than this
deal with amazon and mgm is worth
bringing together two of the biggest
studios in hollywood
disney took over fox and merged into one
new streaming service speaking of making
disney plus the biggest streaming
service out there
nobody had a problem with that deal even
though it did take significantly longer
than this deal has taken it took 15
months for that deal to go through but
there was no legal battle it was just a
very complicated deal for it to go to
the ftc
basically insisted on there being
several rules and provisos about how
their deal was structured
in the same way that they did with the
time warner deal a few years before that
basically they would they don't want
amazon to completely control mgm even
though they would own it they want mgm
to have some autonomy so where are we at
right now
there are three possibilities basically
that i see
the ftc could just
not oppose the deal and that is actually
where we stand at the moment if the vote
stays as two on two the deal will go
through they could not oppose the deal
but begin a legal battle now this is a
legal battle they would almost certainly
lose because legally the deal is
perfectly correct
amazon is not a big studio buying
another big studio when they have
produced stuff for amazon prime in the
past it's normally in partnership with
other studios look at their star trek
picard that's in partnership with cbs
wheel of time was in partnership with
sony
that is how they have been producing
material over the last few years
now the reason why they're buying mgm is
because they want to start making far
more of their own they want to work with
mgm to produce material for amazon the
third possibility though is that they
do oppose the deal and they do go to
court and they win
now that's going to be a massive problem
for mgm as i say they're two billion
quid in debt and technically owned by
their debtors there were other people
that wanted to buy
mgm before this but they were offering
far lower than amazon offered anything
up to 40 percent lower nearly half one
of the big companies there was apple now
apple to me are a very similar company
to amazon in lots of ways they own their
own streaming service already they do
produce some television on a very small
scale and obviously they're an
electronics company i don't really see
any major difference from the ftc's
point of view between apple or amazon
buying mgm
but currently the ftc are making noises
like they are going to refuse this deal
and they are going to begin the legal
battle amazon though have known this for
a little while
go back and look check previous videos
i've told you about how amazon basically
had two plans for stargate
one they wanted to produce a movie
followed by a tv series that however was
dependent on the deal going through by
april may time which is actually a lot
of what mgm executives expect will
happen if there is a legal battle that
could add anything up to six months onto
this and then the sale will go through
towards the end of this year at which
time amazon don't want to then produce a
movie followed by series because they
wanted to have it basically on screens
by 2023 so they'd flip it
they'd produce a tv series followed by a
movie because they can produce a tv
series much quicker than a film they
want to get customers on side with this
deal and they know that one way of doing
that is to bring back the sleeping giant
of sci-fi stargate as quickly to our
screens as possible they would prefer
that to do that with a movie first they
have a lot of big hype
but if they can't they'll do it with the
tv series instead if you are new to the
channel please like subscribe hit that
bell notification hit the thumbs up
thumbs down thumbs down helps nobody and
you can become a fully fledged
sidetracker and support the channel
please consider hitting that join button
as always guys please stay safe i'll see